kicking off with how to handle pastry
lightly flour the surface
pastry on top rolling pin now the secret
now
is don't overwork the pastry firm push
turn the pastry round and this helps to
even the pastry turn
and roll now as it starts to crack don't
worry just by pushing it back together
it sort of Unites the pastry immediately
apply pressure turn the pastry now the
average thickness is down to a one pound
coin back on to the rolling pin
and look
beautiful
for the neatest Edge on Tarts and
quiches my tip is to let the pastry hang
over the side of the tin when you bake
it trim around the edge once the pastry
is cooked it will give you a cleaner
Edge and prevent it from shrinking
quick tip for even Rising is to place
cakes and Tarts in the center of the
oven so the air can circulate all the
way around them
to test your cake to make sure it's done
insert a knife skewer or even a piece of
spaghetti in the center if this mixture
stuck to it it's not done yet
if it comes out clean your Cake's ready
[Music]
if you don't have any baking beans to
hand for blind bacon you can use any
rice grain or poles
you won't be able to cook with them
afterwards but do keep them to reuse
them next time
when you're folding egg whites or
whipped cream into cake mixtures you
want to retain as much air in the
mixture as you can my tip use a metal
spoon as the sharp thin Edge will keep
more of the air in
my first recipe uses lovely buttery
shortcrust pastry to make a dish that's
as delicious as it is simple leek and
pancetta quiche
shortcrust pastry is one of the Staples
of the kitchen it is so versatile but
the good news is it's one of the easiest
pastries to make trust me when you crack
it it can make a real difference to
cookies
take a sieve
what do you think of short crust pastry
it's sort of semi flaky but it's Rich
buttery start by sipping 200 grams of
plain flour into a mixing bowl
large pinch
salt
200 grams of unsalted butter
bring the butter up to room temperature
if you let the butter become too soft
and the flour so it doesn't absorb it in
with your fingers rub together first now
the secret is grab big handfuls and
squeeze the butter into the flour
so look what's happened literally in 30
seconds I've got that nice
crumbly texture
now a couple of tablespoons of water
nothing worse when the pastry is so wet
you can't bring it together it needs to
shape like a nice rich cookie dough it's
just a touch too dry
so one more tablespoon of water
[Music]
there you go
let's cut now
that's what I want a nice sort of
firm ball pastry onto the board
I'm going to use these one of the
strongest parts of the body pull towards
you and push back down use those wrists
it's really need it
together so just that nice sort of
smooth texture
now wrap it in Clinton
sit there in the fridge for 20 minutes
really important that you let the
shortcuts pastry relax
[Music]
now to make the quiche you can use just
an ordinary flan dish but I love making
them in many frying pans which gives
them an extra rustic charm
brush with oil to stop the pastry from
sticking once the pastry is at room
temperature roll it out to a nice even
thickness
place it in the center of your little
pan turn it in don't use your fingers
because what we don't want is any holes
in this just get a little bit of dough
because that sort of acts like a little
sort of mallet slams it out nicely I'm
building a sort of extra lip because
that way I can get the filling that is
absolute maximum levels
when I cut them blind first
to Blind bake simply means to pre-cook
your pastry before adding the filling
this ensures you'll have a fantastic
crisp pastry
add a sheet of foil or baking paper and
weigh it down
[Music]
you can use rice pulses or ceramic
baking Stones just make sure you keep
them for the next time
in the oven 200 degrees for 10 minutes
now for the filling
I'll do a classic quiche bacon and leeks
this is a amazing cured pancetta
it was an Italian cured meat made from
belly pork seasoned with things like
Juniper nutmeg fennel a great substitute
is unsmoked bacon
as the vancetta gets lovely and crispy
finely sliced leeks and add
whoa leeks and bacon nice
really important to cook those leeks
down
exactly what it wants those leaks are
almost sort of caramelized slightly
crispy the flavor's amazing I just drain
them off so any excess fat gets drained
a tablespoon's of cream
it gives it a nice richness
I want two-thirds garnish I.E bacon and
leeks in my quiche and one third of the
Savory custard
salt
Touch of pepper
grates and Greer cheese
that makes a really nice sort of creamy
less of an eggy quiche take my amazing
crispy pancetta and leeks in
give that a good mix
needs one more little thing some
freshness
flat leaf parsley incredible
really important just to taste
um
the mixture with the quiche fitting
ready next finish off the pastry
[Music]
remove the Fallen weight and return to
the oven to get it lovely and golden all
over
[Music]
now when we fill them give that a really
good mix up
[Music]
beautiful great over some more cheese
which will Bubble Up and melt
beautifully and then into the oven
make your keys for 15 to 20 minutes
incredible
it's got that nice sort of cheese and
toast smell from the top it's sort of
baked
secret of any good quiche is in the
short crust because that's the hero
we spectacular when they're done well
and it doesn't come any simpler or more
stylish than my next dish wonderful
baked cheesecake for me food always has
to be impressive but when it comes to
dessert often you see Sponge sugar or
wild decorations remember simple is
always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious
well cream cheese leave it out of the
fridge for five or ten minutes go nice
and soft trust me your arms will be
thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is a New York
cheesecake because it's baked so there's
no base start creaming the cheese and
the sugar
spending the amount of time I do in the
states if there's one thing they know
how to do out there is the most amazing
impressive cheesecake Rich delicious but
so simple work the bowl
lift the ball to your advantage
really whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
creamy now
get your eggs
add the extra mixture bit by bit doing
it this way it's more efficient hey
you're incorporating a lot of Air B the
mixture doesn't separate
Blaster of your egg
of course you can use electric mixer but
if I go to the gym we can just make a
cheesecake a day
keep the Bingo Wings away
now a couple tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk stop something going
Lumpy
now I want to scent that cheesecake
I've got the freshness zest the lemon in
there I want to sort of tart it up even
more fold in some fresh raspberries sort
of just mix them through be careful to
crush them
then grease a cake tin with butter this
will ensure your cheesecake slides out
beautifully
get your mix
let that fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
mixture hits the bottom of the cake tin
The Raspberries rise and you've got
raspberries at the top the middle and
the bottom it also stops all these
little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture and the cake tin
there's no holes
in the cheesecake now into the oven 180
degrees for 35 to 40 minutes
[Music]
hmm
slightly soufflaid up
pull off
[Music]
that's the color I wanted on top
and look at it
it's one of the simplest yet the most
stylish cheesecakes anywhere
beautiful
[Music]